alright guys let's do the questions we
don't talk about the fights we will at
the end the very very end cuz some
people yeah give me the question then
unhelpful advice with Bobby hi Ohana I
went to visit a guy I've been seeing for
a couple months over the weekend fairly
recently and he left me for a few hours
to go to dinner with his friends what
say you about hosts more specifically
someone you're romantically involved
with who ditched their guests with
people they don't know in a city they're
unfamiliar with and come back later than
promised only to give a half-ass apology
and then ghost me shortly after is it as
simple as he may be clueless as [ __ ] or
is this common amongst guys this day and
age mind you this guy claimed he was all
about me said he wants to continue loved
continue seeing me making future plans
stressing there was no one else and etc
it's not that's the end that's the end
yet his actions have shown otherwise
what insight could you guys provide
regarding the situation the end it never
even started because I'm going to tell
you this right now I when I was dating a
girl named Amy and it was I booked a big
job where I had to go to a different
country there's my first like commercial
Dinitz
fly to a different country and I want to
celebrate because I was gonna be gone
for a month and I I told Amy I go yeah
I'm having a dinner but I'm because I
just want to eat with my agent my
manager she doesn't what like I'm not
gonna see you for a month yeah it's an
industry thing no like some [ __ ]
like that I never saw her again yeah but
that's babe did you not want to see her
again when you went well in retrospect
now yeah okay look if if I you and I
first started dating let's say we had a
long-distance relationship you live
let's say four hours away from me I take
a wee maybe we've been talking for two
months romantically though like we're
serious we're interested in each other
yeah
so I go to visit you let's say you're in
New York and I have I spent three days
with you but on the first night that I'm
there I'm there you say you need to go
to dinner quote-unquote and you leave me
for four hours in an
your city oh my god how I'll never see
you again exactly her [ __ ] never see her
go yeah this guy there's only there's
only two things that are possible either
he's he's hiding something he said he's
going out to friends or dinner with
friends [ __ ] he's either out on a
drug fix because and he doesn't want to
admit to you that he's not he's getting
his drug fixed that day he's out with
another woman it has zero interest in
you and he's basically just you know
you're in he's just toying with you know
what I think is this is is that I'm
gonna hang out with my friends because
that's what I always do or whoever this
girl I flew in for a [ __ ]
fling right so she's gonna have her
around town yeah right it's cuz I've
seen it I've seen that with other comics
I've been on tour with comics I'm not
gonna name names I so badly want to but
why can't you just be upfront and say
hey like I don't want anything romantic
let's just [ __ ] for a weekend good say
yes no I don't think she would I would
are you kidding me if there was a guy
that I was attracted to Anissa and he
said would you come out here for three
days and we would just have a [ __ ] fest
I was suddenly abuts you read the
situation some girls you can read that
you can do that with some girls you
can't some girls just won't do you
underestimate a lot of women I think
that you're telling me that all women
would be like that I think that you
underestimate us I think that if a lot
of men could could afford to be a little
bit more honest I think that we would
actually be a lot more receptive to
something like hey I'm gonna be upfront
with you I find you very attractive and
I'd like to have a lot of sex with you
would you come over and if it's no it's
nobody you know see that's the thing if
it's no it's no some guys don't want to
know they want to yes so they're gonna
they feel out the situation with the
vibe but what the girl is putting out
there right so if you want a hundred
percent yes
a guy will lie and figure it out
mold the situation so he can get what he
wants yeah but that then he's just a
manipulative but that's what guys are a
lot of guys are like that let me say
something lady this guy is a scum [ __ ]
horley at pure and simple his [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's a scum [ __ ] he is not for you he
[ __ ] you over yeah yeah it's not it's
not happening oh that would put me over
the edge I that would really upset me
would you confess him and touch his dick
let me touch my feet oh my god would you
confront him in the middle of his dinner
with the friends um no I just would
honestly girls I would stay in a hotel I
would leave his place stay in the hotel
and enjoy myself for the rest of the
weekend without his presence because
that's just rude right even on the most
basic level even if we were just homies
even if I was visiting a friend and a
friend did that to me I'd be like why
did I even come here for yeah you play
host yeah like I'm we're supposed to be
hanging out as friends and then you
leave me to go off with other friends
like that's [ __ ] that's so dumb this
guy needs to get it together yeah
whoever you are yes
[Music]